hello and welcome, i'm james murphy
and today we're writing a sudoku solver
for another leetcode hard interview problem. in
case you're not familiar, sudoku is a puzzle game
played on a 9x9 grid. you have to fill in
the blanks so that every row, every column,
and every block group of three by three cells has
all of the numbers one through nine exactly once.
we're given that the board that we
take into this function is going to
be a valid board with a unique solution.
furthermore we are meant to modify the
board. we're supposed to solve the board
rather than return a copy which is solved.
first things first let's write a main
function which does at least one test case.
so here i take in the board represented as a big
character array and here is the expected answer
that we're supposed to get. then i create a
solution class which is really only needed for
leetcode problems. in a real code base this would
just be freestanding functions, but in any case i
create the solution class, i print out the initial
board i print out what i'm expecting, i do the
solve, and then print out whether or not it did
it correctly. so that's at least one test case
i've written. this function, it's
very straightforward just to convert
this flat board into a vector of vectors and
this little function just to print out the board.
after compiling and running it we can see
that we can print out the initial board,
the expected board, and then our solution hasn't
done anything so of course it doesn't match.
i think sudoku is a classic example of a recursive
backtracking problem where the most obvious thing
to do is look at the possibilities for what moves
can be made, try one randomly, or try the first
one, or try all of them, and then recursively
solve the problem that way. so the real challenge
for this problem is to decide how do i store the
information. well every row column and the three
by three sub blocks need to have all the numbers
one to nine so for each row column and cell i'm
going to keep track of which numbers have already
been used. i've decided to do this using arrays of
bit sets. a bit set is similar to a standard
set except it lets me store all nine elements
in basically a single integer. the way that it
does this is effectively by using an integer
and using the first say nine bits of that integer
to represent whether i have a true or false value
in that location. so if the bit at the zeroth
index, the first bit, is set then i'm using
that to represent that one has already been used.
this is especially useful because i can compute
set operations on bit sets by using
very primitive math operations. like
for instance i can compute the union of two
bit sets just with the "or" operator. i'm
effectively just or-ing the underlying integers
which are made up of those bits. the next step
is to loop over the given board and mark out
all the integers that were already given to us.
i loop over the rows and columns and then
if i see something which is not a blank
then here's what i do. i convert the
digit to an index for the bit set
and then for the given row column and cell i set
the given index as being true, present, i did also
write this little function get cell to compute
which cell i'm in given the row and column. then
i just give all the information i've collected so
far to this solve function which we're going to
write, which is going to do all the heavy lifting
and the recursion and such. the purpose of the row
and column starts here is to tell the algorithm
where to start. basically it should assume that
anything before this row and column start has
already been solved and to just progress forward.
and of course by before or after i'm referring
to an order where you go left to right and then
top to bottom. the first thing that i want
to do is find a position that's a blank,
something that i can fill in. finding the next
empty position is pretty straightforward, i just
loop through and check to see if it's a blank and
otherwise i keep getting the next row and column
where here we see the implementation
of what the next row and column is,
it's just a little bit of math modulus trickery.
it's pretty straightforward. the return value of
next empty position is either a location that has
a blank for me to fill in or it's off the board
so i can use this as my base case, if everything
has been solved up to row 9 then there's nothing
more to do and that's a solution. note here that
9 is one index past the last actual row. the next
thing i do is compute which numbers have already
been used in the current row, column, or cell.
that's what this line does. so remember each of
these things is a bit set so i am or-ing these
sets together. the result is all the numbers that
have already been used. at this point in the code
there must be a dot at the current location so
if everything has been used then there's nothing
i can use to fill in that dot and so we return
false. otherwise we loop over all the possible
digits and if that digit has not been used
already then we start the recursive backtracking.
so here's what i do. i take the digit and
put it on the board. then i mark it as being
used in the corresponding row, column, and
cell, then i recursively solve the problem.
i'm using the return value of solve to indicate
whether or not solve succeeded. if the solve is
true that means i was able to complete the
board and find the unique solution after
making the guess that i made. otherwise solve
returned false and so i need to undo that guess.
so i unmark that guess from the row, column,
and cell, and then move on to the next guess.
if none of the guesses succeed, then importantly
i need to reset the current location to a blank
and then say this failed. i wasn't able
to complete the board given the current
stuff that's in the board. this allows me to
backtrack up and potentially give another guess
at an earlier stage. and that's pretty much it.
back up here in the main solve sudoku function
i also want to point out that in a real code base
i would definitely want to check the return value,
whether the final solve worked, but in this case
we're given that any input is going to have a
unique solution so we don't need to check it. okay
so i compiled it and ran it and you can see that
with the initial looking like this, and the
expected looking like this, we do indeed find
that we have a success and our algorithm
was able to successfully solve the sudoku.
all right i went ahead and submitted it and we
saw that the run time was four milliseconds,
faster than about 98 percent, and less memory
usage than about 96 percent, so pretty good.
that's all i have for this episode. if you liked
it be sure to tell your friends, subscribe,
and don't forget to slap that like button
an odd number of times. see you next time.